when I go for a walk or I exercise I
will literally say to myself
you're giving yourself an intravenous
dose of Hope like I think this is how we
should frame movement that that it's
something you can choose to do to really
powerfully influence your mental health
and your resilience and every time you
move you're doing that I think to know
that to like look at your own muscles
and be able to say thank you legs you're
tired now that was hard work but like
legs you're you are a pharmacy that of
antidepressants and resilience and hope
when you move on a regular basis your
brain basically says I guess we have to
be the best version of ourselves because
we're in this thing called life